I can't believe it's been 20 years still
gonna take her father into the
anniversary we wouldn't be here if it
wasn't Fran
on this day in 1996 the world escaped
the clutches of extinction your father
was the bravest man I've ever seen we
all lost someone we love
but in their sacrifice we found the 10
to build a stronger and safer earth
as our survival is only possible when we
stand together
oh my god a distress call - screaming
they're not screaming they're
celebrating they're coming back it has
its own gravity
what goes up must come down
shouldn't we be nervous um yeah
our whole lives built up to this moment
it's touchdown over the Atlantic which
high all of it
make them pay not going up there to make
friends we've gotten remind them earth
is not for the taking
Oh
I have years to get us ready we never
had a chance we didn't last time either
we convinced an entire generation
this is a battle that we could win we
sacrifice for each other no matter what
the cost
and that's worth fighting for support
the July let's show them some fireworks
they like to get the landmarks